I want to back up a little bit to some
of your history because you weren't oh
is a public person and a journalist and
someone that's you know staked out
controversial positions you're actually
you were a private citizen you were in
banking at first right yeah
what what blessed you to go from a
normal job to somebody that's that's out
there putting their their face with
their words I know I was a sign industry
with the good prospects and good income
and you know that man don't want miss
growth it just wasn't for me I thought I
want to I want to go into an industry
where there's massive job losses where
I'm gonna be the tiniest of tiny
minorities it wasn't completely planned
it was fairly accidental but it was a
happy accident and you know I did decade
in in in finance and I think I enjoyed
my stupid but by the end of it I just
had enough and I had much violence at
that point too so it sort of gave me an
opportunity to rethink things I went
back to university I did my masters
which was again that's kind of cemented
some of my thoughts about higher
education than just how many junk
degrees there are just completely
pointless just sadly oh you basically
said that you think higher education is
a waste all together right oh no no not
a waste all together I just think in
Australia in particularly way there are
so many of these chunk degrees that
don't qualify you to do anything that
saddle students with big debts raise
their expectations and they come out and
they're no more qualified for a job than
they went when they went in and you know
a lot of it is just left indoctrination
posing as education it's just absurd
and you know I'm all for having even
more degrees for you know doctors and
nurses and architects and accountants
things that actually you know teach you
how to do a certain job but you know
bloody masters in gender dance there
something else is just right anyway um
so yeah it was old again it wasn't
planned I was by chance and just finding
myself I guess so that's such a wanky
term but anyway Here I am and it's it's
worked out well yeah so here you are
it's worked out well we connected on
Twitter I don't know maybe six months
ago or so and I thought wow here's
someone else across the world who gets
it who you know I sense cares about the
same things I care about I see you every
now and again you fight with some of the
haters I'm not big on fighting with the
haters as a general rule and I see them
spewing all sorts of genuinely racist
awful things that you they often they
often think that you're another
nationality than you are or religion I
was in fact yesterday I had someone I
told them I'm not Indian because you
know all their sort of abuse was framed
around me being Indian or Hindu like
never never don't know anybody there had
never been there no way and they just
refused to accept it that I've know you
are Indian acceptable arias look it is a
really fine balance I tell people you
know if I'm giving them advice about
Twitter's is like don't feed the trolls
don't acknowledge them their attention
seekers they're desperate for any sort
of attention so don't give them what
they looking for but on the other hand
every now and then I don't know my
followers enjoyed it's good to you know
call out some filthy hypocrite and just
highlight BDC highlight the ADC and
hypocrisy and vileness of some of these
social justice warriors who think you
know their their morals are pristine and
who think they're better than the rest
of us but they're quite offer and a
fairly vile human beings and I'm happy
to mock them I'm happy to you know
highlight them to the followers and let
them have their fun with them um but i
acknowledge the other way your way which
is just don't acknowledge them because
you know i get literally from days
thousands and
thousands of mentions and I came and
read all of them and I certainly don't
you know respond to all of them
and it does seem like sometimes you know
the overwhelming bulk are decent
comments intelligent comments that
you're not acknowledging and you're
acknowledging the lewd lunatic and that
seems to be sort of Kanchi
counterintuitive but I think we've got
to highlight the mentality of these
people particularly when they pretend to
be morally superior to the rest of us
right so that that's an interesting
piece of this because we've got the
social justice warrior class that are
moralizing all of us and telling us how
racist we are in all this nonsense and
then at the same time there absolutely
is a piece of this alt right thing that
I've talked about a bit a bit on this
show where I get it they're there Pepe
the Frog and Harambee and they're
trolling everybody and then they get
Hillary to talk about the Frog and
they're just internet meme posters their
posters and they want to upset
everybody and they're I think they're
perfectly harmless but I also do see the
the real white nationalist stuff and I
don't know how much of that so my
question she really is do you think it's
just I go back and forth basically
between thinking that it's healthy when
they get this stuff out because then
it's not just hidden and secretive and
even though they're anonymous whatever
they're getting it out versus on another
hand in the last year I have seen more
blatant true hate than ever before
online so I'm not sure which one I
whether I think this is actually healthy
or or not yeah I haven't set my mind to
that - I'm not sure I mean it does seem
like an absolute sewer at times tweet
her you know yeah more so than any other
social media forum it seems to be just a
bio fields were full of people who are
miserable who just want a fight yeah
that those are really not nasty nazi
types i haven't encountered too many
i've had a few and i've just bought them
but they've been very few in numbers as
far as the ones attacking me so that i'm
not sure of the size
of that population I don't think it's
anywhere near the size of the of the
other side but yeah any sign of them
isn't healthy and again I think they
should be treated with absolute disdain
that should be called out there should
be mocked and that's what I tend to do I
don't try to you know convince these
people and try to re-educate them I just
mock them because that's all they
deserve they don't deserve your time
they don't deserve you know and I think
Twitter's are really dumb for them for
in-depth arguments you know you just
can't have them it's just that's not the
place for discussions where you try to
frame your point of view in us fewer
characters as possible and if you're
actually trying to have a proper
discussion I just don't think that's the
forum for yeah do you see a new center
sort of lining up all over the world
because I think even a year ago or so
people were barely talking about this
I'm talking about the people that are
not the far right true white
supremacists or racist or whatever you
want to call them and you know I don't
like using all the buzzwords and not and
not the regressive left and all the
sjw's and all that but that there is
some sort of new center lining up and
it's because of the internet because
people like us have been able to to
connect that my friend Ally R is be up
in Canada who's the atheist Muslim
coined the phrase the new center he said
that's that's the new home politically
do you says that this could actually
become a political movement absolutely I
think political parties are starting to
recognize what the electric cares about
and they you've got to think the
Republicans have to regroup over the
next decade and recognize that they
abandoned their base that you know they
had so many people so desperately
unhappy with them and so eager to jump
on the on the Trump train and in
Australia as well you know in the last
election something between one or two
million vote two million voters and
that's a significant figure here we're a
small country of conservative voters
took their vote elsewhere from from the
mainstream conservative liberal Nash
coalition so I think there is this new
Center and where it is is the question I
think it's a far more to the right then
the media class would want it to be and
acknowledge it to be I don't mean their
right wing
I just think that you know in their
economic point of view in their attitude
to borders and immigration and national
security they're far more conservative
then then the media class would like
them to be and acknowledge them to be so
I think the politicians have no choice
but to acknowledge it yeah they can't
ignore it their political survival
depends on it so but whether you
actually see the emergence of a new
party is something else to to ponder I'm
not sure about that but there's talk of
that in Australia let's talk about an
actual new conservative party that will
bring in all these sort of minor parties
voters but it hasn't happened it's
something that's been talked about but
whether it actually eventuates is
another yeah I think it's interesting
that you know a second ago you started
to say that they're more right but you
really meant conservative and then you
you fix yours yeah but you know but I I
bring that up only because it's like
even people like you to make your point
you still want to be so concerned about
the language and I feel that too because
we're we're so just under this thing
where if you say one thing wrong and
imply that the Conservatives are really
far right or that that everyone will be
all over you and that what if what a
crazy place for people like us to be in
oh it's insane these people are just so
hypersensitive yeah and so looking to be
offended by something or take something
out of context that you do sometimes you
know even if someone who doesn't want to
doesn't give a stuff about political
correctness you find yourself qualifying
things and explaining things like you
over explaining things it's yeah it's
it's I guess we're not immune to it
either when we live in that world and we
have to acknowledge it I wish we were
over I see people on Twitter telling me
sometimes Dave we could see it get over
yourself
like you know just stop but you know I'm
still trying to be a person that a good
person that exists in 2016 so so my last
my last question for you is taking
everything that we've discussed here
what do you think the best thing for for
people that are that are hearing our
message is whether they're a little more
right or conservative or a little more
left or liberal or whatever it is for
all of these people that are hearing
this and seeing the same trends that
you're talking about all over the world
what is the best thing that they can do
to help fix some of this stuff ah be
brave be bold say what you think I think
that's the the message to take out of it
don't be afraid don't be bullied into
silence don't feel like your point of
view isn't worthy of being aired and
discussed and don't worry about you know
if you say something you're gonna be
unfriended on Facebook where someone you
went to school with 20 years ago you
know I just think people need to be
people need to be braver and have and be
interested yeah believe it I wouldn't
force anybody to to become political
nuts but you know if you care about this
stuff get interested read read different
sources find out what's really happening
and don't be shy about putting your two
cents in yeah well that's what I say on
on the show every week so I will cosign
that one all right well Rita it was a
pleasure I'm so glad we finally
connected and we were supposed to have
you a couple days ago in our Internet
blew out I think we somebody's watching
us and they didn't want us to connect it
was I don't believe that was just
coincidence there's obviously some sort
of left-wing conspiracy to silence us
yeah I don't think there's any other
explanation possible definitely some
sort of left-wing conspiracy anyway you
guys can follow Rita it's at Rita Panahi
on Twitter and she you can follow her
writing over at the Australian Herald
Sun and Rita it was a pleasure so we'll
we'll keep doing this in 140 characters
you